feel like I need some hot cheetos I like
my blackness with a little bit of hot
cheeto
[Music]
hi I'm dree Adama and today I'm watching
poetic justice for the first time hi
everyone I'm Sean hall and the movie
that I will be watching for the first
time as a belly I'm done with t Pongo
and I am watching coming to America hi
I'm Taryn and I will be watching a thin
line between love and hate
hi my name is Jumeirah and I will be
reacting to Waiting to Exhale hello my
name is Julius when this came out and I
was a shorty we were not checking for
coming to America man I'm a first
generation West African Ghanian and I
never heard as a Munda I have not seen
this film for a few reasons
one I was a child I just always remember
seeing the car scene and Angela Bassett
burning that gentleman's BMW and I was
like maybe there's not a movie for me I
haven't seen this film because honestly
there hasn't been a reason for me to do
it I mean I've seen baby boy I feel like
it has the same premise I've never seen
for what existed because I grew up I
would say a little bougie
I couldn't enter up elementary school
like hey teach I can't make because I'm
gonna go see belly yeah I mean it looks
overweight it looks overrated to me well
this got Taye Diggs this got the black
actors of like the black Avenger actors
it's already starting bogus like I hate
that miscellaneous African music they
play like it all like random drums and
it's like The Lion the Lions we used to
know whatever the other song is before
we start where this title come from I I
just want to know why this is like
literally the cliche 90s black film
because it started as like oh I bet
you're wondering how I got in this
position well it all started last week
when my mama okay all right
Loretta Devine got that doo rag on she's
not going anywhere for New Year's Eve
yeah well miss
Oh Oh this action is terrible it is my
duty foe oh my goodness this is not the
next interval stop to pop just popped
out the middle truck [ __ ] man man he's
very mean like I thought mail me was
supposed to be friendly he got a potty
mouth
he crotchety he's putting Vaseline on
the drugs okay because everything has to
be moisturized even your drugs drugs
have to be moisturize okay yeah James
Earl Jones got good African uncle vibes
for real I am talking to my son
yeah that's I got an uncle like that
right now think he does he drive a taxi
no he ain't rich you just talk like that
oh yeah sex quick is finished she's out
this is this is so like it's like
looking at a mirror okay there's my
first problem why I present Wayne never
made you happy when I asked why are you
not smiling he walked in the door coming
for Janet you ain't got no man cuz you
don't smile I've been doing this for 20
years oh my god hold on just cuz the CD
skip don't mean the sex is over like you
you can work through it cuz I didn't did
some things to Kirk Franklin just hit
that hit that a forward button you VI
Darnell need therapy Darnell was Martin
Lawrence's character also I don't I
don't trust Minnie Darnell's let's see
if I send your heart acting a little
better than it is now let's see if you
could defend yourself you sweat from a
baboon's balls nice accents here puts it
up on him like this he just jumped over
died like a little rabbit I thought so
[ __ ] supposed to be a gangster this is
not scary by a person comes to the door
knocks on the door say hey you know your
cars on fire
yup and I burnt myself fireman it was
like a loving hip-hop like episode
except
longer and directed by Forest Whitaker
now says teeth
Africa because that's where you going
medially what but life just gets to you
mind you it's never our country
mentioned not Ghana nah Morocco not
Somalia nowhere just Africa so like in a
parallel universe this is Ricky from
boys in the hood who survived the shot
that went on to the lead I know crazy
Bobby Brown probably at lived every
single line in this film it's only it's
not even ten minutes into this and I can
tell he didn't learn a damn line hard on
now I just want to know if Maya thought
of rest of this movie like this she
bless this mess because I just don't
know if she has seen everything that
stuff was gone why would she have
approved and he dedicated the book to
them scandal he talks to the club owner
Swift Smitty talking about son
oh yeah I think I think she's the one I
can settle down just yesterday he was
talking about you're too young so what
is it is it well she Wiley or is it one
Mike this goes to show you that men can
wear anything to bed or when they're
about to have sex like she has on
beautiful lingerie her hair is done him
t-shirt plaid underwear but it's outfit
I can tell his toenails are not cut so
is this the movie that people actually
enjoy you know what I mean like is this
like oh I'm chilling on a Saturday
nothing's happening let's watch poetic
justice oh I know this is authentic
African right here she's sitting on a
swing he comes up with the code with the
champagne
at this moment in time I'm still
confused I thought it was like the
blueprint for a show like girlfriends
are insecure because they had women who
were liberated whether it was mentally
emotionally or sexually they were
liberated in some way shape or form then
we're making the right decisions at all
like they were making piss-poor
decisions but we saw women not being
guided more so by men and more so like
just lightning can up on now I think
when with Bill you know she acted her we
see why she does the things that she
does today we see why she has cemented
her place in Hollywood Regina King of
course I kind like give her all things
as well Martin hey hopefully I don't
have to see it again
I definitely learned a lesson it's not
about what happened in the past
it's what what's happening now and what
can happen in the future so the best man
was really good I'm impressed dying in
the press
the film was gorgeous it was stunning
however that kind of confuse me a bit
not gonna lie to you but cool I still at
the end of this film don't know why it's
caught belly but maybe one of you can
answer for me let me know
I'm desirably John Singleton nothing
personal I just really feel like I want
my Chihuahua's back and my 399 because
that's how much it costs to write it
I give it a solid suit when I watch it
again only a BuzzFeed asked me to
you